uncompromising and it's going to be hard
for Anish to kind of just shut the shut
the gates and kind of knuckle down in a
solid position okay we start with a
ready opening very flexible Daft Anton
plays everything right Lawrence every
opening others oh yes
David and some very very versatile
player uh doesn't feel uncomfortable in
in really any position and today he's
just playing uh a collie uh I mean
Bishop B2 I mean this is the most
aggressive star
I'm expecting there to be fireworks and
I really thought that the vedanta would
just go hard and and Anish of course
playing the most principled line in fact
developing the light squared Bishop now
this is actually quite critical already
for the white side because David
actually extracts something he's gonna
be just level I mean he will have
nothing from the opening I mean it's
basically a coincidence
reverse colors it's as if uh David Anton
he was like I prefer playing with a
black piece of so I'll play a black
opening and uh and he's he's gonna love
this so white does have the bishop pair
I guess that's the only real imbalance
the pawn structure something we call the
Carlsbad structure there's a lot of
material out there in books
um and video content about this Pawn
structure from the Queen's Gambit
usually it can also arise from the
karakania banker yep and a few others
this position looks actually very
similar to a caricon defense
uh but yeah it's gonna take a slower
turn now while both sides try to come up
with plans
I've got to agree I'm not a huge fan of
this uh opening by David Anton but it's
a playable position still a lot of life
left and it's a reason because it's not
something you would play in a must-win
situation yeah I'm not sure it suits
your strengths anisha's kind of got a
solid foundation Black's Pawn structures
very harmonious uh black has a clear
plan or two as well black can play on
the queen Side by pushing Black's A and
B pawns later that's something we call a
minority attack actually it's quite rare
to push pawns on the side that you're
weaker where you have fewer uh fewer
pawns but and you can also push in the
center later David Anton he's got to
play with pieces he doesn't really want
to push with pawns anytime soon but uh
okay the white pieces are coming out now
it takes a while to get them to their
ideal squares
the issue for white I must say I'm a big
fan of the position for black yeah not
for white I mean yeah white has the
bishop pair but I mean if you take a
look at the pawn structure you can see
it's relatively stable and no side is
going to be advancing pawns as David
mentioned and there's also no clear Pawn
breakthroughs and I think this favors
the knights and uh there we see the
light Square Bishop drop back and it's
probably going to maneuver itself again
to a better diagonal is this an optical
illusion though because if we had this
position with reverse colors so if we
had White's position but with black
where it would normally arise in the
Queen's Gambit we would be like yeah I'm
fine out of the opening I've survived
I've equalized
maybe it's just I've got an extra Tempo
because we start with the white pieces
um yeah it's it's kind of hard to
explain but for those out there those
viewers who do play the Queen's gamber
declined as black this type of position
that we now see for white it must be
very very familiar
ah it's very strange to uh to just kind
of play a less ambitious opening but
with one extra Tempo like this and it's
not very his style David Anton is that
what you said
um not usually usually he's got some
kind of tricky ideas up his sleeve and
whatever he plays or usually he likes to
challenge the opponent quite early on
he's taking a slower approach and uh
okay giri meanwhile pausing this is what
we're used to seeing from the top
players when they're about to come up
with a middle game plan
we're done with the opening both sides
of castled
it's just formulating a plan over the
next five six moves that's why he
stopped he'll maybe think for another
minute or two a niche then he'll play a
few moves very very quickly
but yeah I mean from the caricana Ivanka
you have a lot of experience maybe if we
jump in just to show where some of the
pieces go or some of the usual plans
okay Black's Queen moving very logical
why is that logical
um I guess you want to connect the Rooks
ah okay at the end of any opening now
the Rooks are flexible the Queen's in
the way previously so this Rook couldn't
really step anywhere decent it could
step behind a pawn but it's a bit
blocked in there so now the queen moves
and black can choose maybe to bring the
Rook to this square or maybe this Square
often for example if white moves his
Bishop Ivanka you mentioned that this is
maybe a better Square for the white
Bishop staring down this uh this side of
the board maybe black can even consider
at some point bringing his Rook across
and pushing these pawns you have to time
this correctly but the idea would be for
example if white does nothing to launch
that Minority attack so often two pawns
they Bear Down against three pawns and
the whole idea is no matter what happens
now where the white captures or whether
white kind of leaves it the the trade of
these pawns will leave white with an
isolated one no matter what
so okay Black's played according to a
normal Square
expecting this move what would happen
next for example if black
weights
how would we put up well I mean I'd have
three is yeah is kind of very standard
here and there's one thing that black
has to be careful with because if you
take a look at the pawns the pawns are
pointing to the left and you're like hey
all the all the fun and games is going
to happen on the left side that is true
but you always have to take care of the
king and take a look at the black king
doesn't have too many Defenders around
it so as long as black is prepared to
guard the king and just be aware that uh
it could be in danger then it should be
fine and he pushes a little porn move
over there and that's primarily to say
to the dark Square Bishop that white has
I mean where are you gonna go what
Square are you gonna develop to my
friend chess is like that we're a bit
mean at times and it gives us certain
satisfaction but on the other hand that
that uh pawn move also has its danger as
well because it's it's the porn move and
the bishop could sacrifice itself at the
right time and blast open the king later
you need to prepare it but okay the pawn
structure has actually changed so Anish
doesn't want to just sit patiently uh in
the this position he blasts things open
and this looks exactly like a variation
of the caricon now that I've had many
times before myself and after a trade of
Pawns a white knight offers an exchange
and
isolated Queen's Pawn the iqp as we call
it
yes isolated yes it comes up from a
bunch of openings that Queen's Gambit
from the karakan from French defense
from uh
um there are a lot so these players
they'll be familiar with the ideas
usually this Pawn it's nice to blockade
it especially with a knight in the
center because that would be an outpost
for the white knight uh also you don't
want to trade off too many pieces
because the more pieces that disappear
the weaker this Pawn will become so is
that now a super strong uh piece in our
niche's camp uh the pawn yeah yes at the
moment at least so it does control a lot
of central squares and black has great
piece play but yeah again you have to be
careful certain end games will be very
bad for black because of its weakness
and okay I was going to say there's a
choice of which piece to take first
um I often in these Pawn structures
actually take the Knight but he decides
to take the bishop and now again the
question is peace is coming off the
board is this a strength or weakness
why has a simple plan you just park your
Bishop in the center maybe even on the
Square and you just centralize your
Rooks and black has to kind of just sit
and wait and Hope
that it the structure is not too uh too
deficient and uh it's on the board yeah
it's
it's really interesting okay and he's
really begging to exchange pieces
um it's just interesting that Anish is
willing to go into a slightly worse
position I think
um just because he's confident in his
defensive skills yeah I mean
the irony is people watching this at
home if if you've got a basic knowledge
of the theory of isolated Queen's Pawn
positions it's that when you've got the
isolated Queen school and you're
supposed to keep pieces on the board
especially minor pieces because you've
got great peace play so you want to use
those pieces for an attack but a niche
is voluntarily exchanging his pieces and
theoretically with every single exchange
his position should be slightly worse
because in the end white is going to try
and basically blockade like uh David is
David Anton is doing now and when that
D5 Pawn note Kaya held the white Pawn
structure is very very solid two porn
Islands the pawns are connected no real
weaknesses whereas black has got this
glaring weakness now on D5 the good news
for Anish is that it's well protected at
the moment and he can still as for
example the move rookie 4 show Great
Piece play uh nevertheless white has got
what we call a a long-term static
advantage and static in the sense that
the D5 Pawn is
static it cannot be exchanged it cannot
be traded so that's there for a long
time it's not a strength anymore
pros and cons pros and cons yes it's
probably more of a weakness and a
strength I would say but I really like
anisha's last move for example rookie
for it wouldn't be possible uh this Rook
move unless he had this Central Pawn
supporting uh Square sorry yeah I know I
was just going to say one of the things
that you have to bear in mind when you
do have a structural weakness like that
weak Pawn is that you should go about
controlling open lines and I like and
issues move as well and now David
Anton's move took me by surprise because
that's uh weakening the king a little
bit but it's asking the question to The
Rook where are you gonna go you're going
to step back are you going to trade
um probably has to step take a step all
the way back
back again dare I do so he's lost two
moves on each Gary but he has provoked
this slightly weakening move as you say
Ivanka and the reason it's slightly
weakening is actually that whites pushed
this Pawn as well so there are holes
kind of uh on the dark squares
and I mean if this Pawn was back one
square I would say okay this is great
for white this Pawn dominates the Black
Knight but
uh yeah it's still very hard to come up
with a productive plan do you like the
move
yeah I mean I'm serious uh you put the
King on G2 you control some squares you
want to start attacking wow I just want
to find a safe haven for my king it's
out of the pin
um the type of move that David Anton
might play actually I've seen him do
similar things before is it so
ridiculous here I'm not so sure yeah
because Black's Knight is far away from
taking advantage of these kind of weak
squares that you've left behind feel so
loose I mean as someone who thrives on
the counter attack I'm like come on give
me those squares okay maybe later yeah
later I mean this move is quite nice by
David Anton you know just securing those
dark squares and uh whoa it's an
exciting day and we love it when you're
at home also join in on the action share
with us your selfies your pictures your
thoughts and you can do that by tweeting
us using the hashtag chess Champs and
also you mentioned earlier on Kaya that
you know we do have the chance for our
expert David to analyze your games using
aim chess and I do quite like donkey
chassis tweets where he says I need help
because I keep making the same mistakes
hashtag help me David retreats
yeah the queen is actually eyeing up
some of those squares we mentioned that
white has uh Left Behind essentially
with those Pawn pushers Black's Queen
now on a really nice diagonal could
swoop in at some point
um that's just kind of a
you know an annoying move I would say
just hinting that the queen will come in
maybe it doesn't even want to but David
until now forever has to guard those
dark squares around the white king
still very very tense roughly level but
can David Anton create anything against
Black's isolated one
maybe it's just uh gonna be a long long
grind when all the Rooks disappear which
they will most likely eventually
probably now right takes takes rookie
one is just the the absolutely standard
continuation yeah and it will come down
to an end game of Queen and Knight
against Queen and Knight again with
better Pawn structure for white but
minimal minimal Firepower left yeah yeah
and also white in the end game and still
have to look after the king now that the
Queens are on the ward
yeah I mean David and maybe the dream
scenario would be getting the Rooks off
and the Queen's off yeah
um if it's just queens and pawns if the
knights disappear probably that's still
a draw as well but if you get the Queens
off and the Rooks off so it's just
Knights and pawns left maybe then some
chances because White's night will
always be superior to the black uh to
its counterpart
again we're talking kind of long-term
strategy and looking for tiny tiny small
advantages and he says yes you can trade
Rooks but on my terms maybe it's now
time for the white king
take a step forward
oh my God that would be such a gutsy
move if it happened I mean
in the end game white king can join the
fun yeah yeah but still the queen of
Rook I mean it's something to be advised
with caution you know take care don't
just March your king up the board
especially when the Rooks and Queens on
the board
um yeah I would be terrified
with good reason but that's because I
forget to look at where my king is oh I
mean if you do a quick uh one one piece
of advice that I got given when I was a
kid I used it quite extensively was like
just before you make a move you sit on
your hands I mean it sounds so
Elementary and you just do a quick like
board scan and you just think about the
move that you on the verge are playing
yeah and you just go does it drop does
it fall off can my opponent do anything
to win it and if the answer is no go
ahead and play it yeah
yeah
yeah I think we'll see that movie if not
now then over the next two or three
turns
them and okay the Rogue steps forward so
like let's take the Rocks off but none
of them want to like initiate it after
you yeah they're both gentlemen
no you go first no but it's it's
actually with good reason because
basically neither side wants to concede
the only open file on the board so for
example let's say black were to take
here uh David to illustrate this point
if black takes a queen takes and white
now the queen has got all of that open
space so it's a bit of
as you guys are saying no you you please
first sir but white now has got an
opportunity let's say black with a
Player move like A6 here which is also a
very logical movement white can now come
behind the with the queen and
effectively Force the trade because now
there's no real way to keep the Rook on
there there might be some funky way but
it looks a bit artificial but yeah and
then white can claim a small victory
here because he's got the open fault is
it enough well it's very very little
but the end game is all about collecting
those small little advantages I mean you
you get your basket and you go Butter
King a better Queen better pawns uh open
file open Line yeah I mean this is
everything and slowly they build up to
something quite unpleasant and the
psychological pressure as well let's not
forget that and the bar is slowly going
up for David Anton now up to 0.5 I think
that's the most it's been all game yeah
it's unlikely we'll see the evaluation
bar swing drastically in one side's
favor but it could be that kind of slow
incremental gains like you guys say and
I think you're right Lawrence will see
most likely this queen move maybe you go
back yeah one of these two squares just
to nudge the rook and say okay after you
and I mean the other move we might see
is this king move we mentioned that it's
a bit scary sometimes but the white king
is pretty safe and we do indeed see your
plan Lawrence
um the queen drops back and white
occupies the open file no entry points
uh this square is covered this square is
covered by the Black Knight so you can't
create repent of the black position yet
but black now has to be a bit Vigilant I
think the white King's coming next move
yeah Queen B6 we're gonna say Lawrence
yeah yeah I was gonna say I mean also uh
in a lot of these positions white can uh
put the knight in a more aggressive
Outpost a night on F5 Kaya yeah and now
on F5 or three out for example you've
seen it before yeah
Kasparov once said a knight on F5 was
worth nearly a whole Pawn wow it's not
quite in this position when you've got a
lot of other pieces on the board and
you're attacking that night is just so
brutal because it touches all of the
sort of sensitive points around the
black king
um and it when it can't be kicked away
it's a very annoying piece in this
position because there's such a
reduction of material there's only an
additional Queen it's not such a big
deal but even a lonely little Knight on
F5 can sometimes cause you yeah
difficulties another thing in the basket
yeah and that's why in the game Anish uh
he's played this queen move first he was
attacking a pawn this was dealt with by
the pawn stepping forward but
um he's trying to prevent that idea of
Lawrence's uh this night move because
now he's staring down on the same
diagonal as the white pieces I mean it
could be a factor for example if
okay let's say the black queen moves um
it could be a factor that David Anthony
could still play this move either now on
the next few turns Knight F5 and he's
saying okay if you don't trade off the
Queens right now then the White Knight
is going to be really scary it's going
to be really strong and the queen
exchange we mentioned that this end game
again is not much but it's slightly
better for white because Black's Knight
is always going to be tied down to this
isolated Pawn
so it's again tiny little things here in
the current position uh David Anton has
maybe a small threat of the White Queen
getting active that is an entry square
into the black camp
expecting a niche to deal with that
and David Anton he knows this is game he
most likely needs to win
so will we see him take some risks in
this game
um at some point at the moment will most
likely come where he'll have to do
something whether that's taking
advantage of a mistake from a niche or
whether it's kind of bluffing a niche or
kind of creating a threat or two that
might be hard to react to but so far
he's using a strategy that works quite a
lot actually
um I most think mostly thinking of
Casper of against karpov I think it was
in Seville and uh Casper needed to win
the final game to keep his title uh
either if a draw copper would have
regained the world championship title
and Kasparov just went really slowly
about his business and eventually cop up
cracked everyone thought he was just
going to attack from the move one it's
Casper over after all but uh he just
played on his opponent's nerves and
David and Tony he will have seen
yesterday Gary was a bit nervous took a
couple of quick draws and dab dance
won't be like okay I'm gonna have a
slightly better position you're going to
be fighting for the draw you're going to
forget about any winning chances and I'm
going to slowly slowly
play on your nerves play on your
negativity
so interesting strategy oh that's
interesting yeah when was that the world
championship game you said Seville 1990
I think
I'm not the best is chess historian out
there but it was a long long time ago so
everyone was shocked when kaspara didn't
play to his normal style yeah exactly he
adapted things just because he
he's very patient and that's rare in a
must-win situation that's what David
Anton is showing now very much patience
and okay the queen does choose an active
Square
just keep an eye on some of the white
port of the white pawns but also
controlling E7 the White Queen wanted to
go there remember
and now surely the white king joins in
well I like this move because let's say
you do play King F2 is his idea to play
Queen A3 and just bother these pawns but
of course you can defend them easily
with Queen E2 or queen D2 but maybe he's
gonna just poke around there so maybe
you think poke around this side of the
board yeah for example Queen E2 might
actually be a mistake because Queen C1
there might be a bit so you want black
to start sneaking in yeah from behind
and start attacking some pawns exactly I
guess that's why David Anton decided in
the current position
um this is actually quite a clever move
this is the only undefended point in the
whole white Camp the only undefended one
so he pushed it forward so now if the
black queen comes in it's not actually
attacking anything
very clever actually it comes in anyway
the Knight does defend this Pawn however
and uh and she's just saying the White
Queen can't come in it can't use this
Square because Black's Queen covers that
square and again it can't kind of even
sneak in this way because of some nasty
checks
this Pawn would suddenly drop yeah and
because of those checks I think it's
high time for the white king to hide
itself away and that's the square I
always think of you know use as a pawns
as a shield and then you know there's
still the idea of the White Queen you
know jumping forward to the fifth row or
to the seventh row or to even the night
coming at the right time oh we have a
check
yeah it's very exciting when we get
checks yeah it's like what's gonna
happen is the king gonna run away is a
pawn gonna step forward first track of
the game I think
it's been a while and uh okay this check
if the King goes back then at the very
least black could go back and repeat the
position uh or maybe he could even jump
in this way towards the white king
I'm expecting a pawn block
but again once you every Pawn push you
make you can't go backwards with Pawn
suddenly the black queen can come back
and suddenly the second rank is
undefended it's open yeah it's not ideal
actually and the white king is not gonna
find a good safety point I mean
I mean Haven if you were to kind of try
to hide on a different Road like the
third row I mean it's still not going to
be very easy because the the queen kind
of find ways to sneak behind get checks
suddenly this king is uh it's not
ideally placed
but how else to block this check if you
push this Pawn forward you give a key
Square in the center of the ball to the
Black Knight now we see that Black's
isolator Pawn is really strong and
anchoring this Outpost oh no okay we've
seen this position happen for a second
time Diamond Aton definitely won't go
for the draw though
um he won't repeat the position for a
third time he'll try something different
I've never really played anyone in the
world as ambitious and as draw a verse
as David Anton every game I play him he
tries to fight for the win and Loris has
moved on the board she's an accent no
you have to do with the accent David
before
um makes a lot of sense you give your
king a bit more breathing room and
sometimes the king can just sit on G2 or
sometimes even G3 as David is showing it
restricts the Knight a bit more on F6 I
would have preferred it a few moves ago
because I am a little loose around the
back but
yeah I mean as as the bar is showing
showing it says zero zero zero I do
believe the position is probably equal
but I think it's probably a little bit
more tricky for black to play but Queen
B2 is a very logical move yeah cutting
the king off so the king can't advance
and also tying down the White Knight to
this Pawn the White Knight has to stay
defending the White Queen has to stay
defending here but I was gonna say
there's nothing else to do those pieces
are tied down push Harry the H Pawn
that's the Modern Trend and there is a
specific idea here white wants to push
the G Pawn forward now that is supported
by its buddy and the Black Knight will
be kicked away suddenly Black's King
will feel a bit loose if this Defender
it's uh its Guardian the Knight is
removed so okay slowly heating up
despite what the evaluation Bar says uh
both players have been playing quite
quickly
um but it's a niche now dealing with a
threat against this Knight why didn't he
push Harry two squares uh it was already
on H3 already on uh that's why you know
if it had been on H2 he would have
played the same if pushed it two squares
so you're right Kai um it's more
important to just support the pawn next
to it and and if he pushes this Pawn
could he just take it with the H Pawn
that's right yeah that will happen and
this is why we needed Harry to support
because Harry Will recapture and the
status quo continues where essentially
you need a pawn to kick away the Black
Knight if in this position uh White had
been too hasty not pushed Harry if he'd
pushed Gary first then after a capture
white can only take with a queen but
that wouldn't do anything it wouldn't
threaten anything and actually White's
Queen would be losing defense of some
other pawns and a niche wow interesting
move uh in the game situation I kind of
met with the threat of pushing this Pawn
forward he's just saying yeah you do it
you go ahead
locking things up so now
this has got to be critical right it has
to be critical I mean I guess anisha's
idea is basically the Night wall Retreat
to any square and then it's going to
park itself on the f8 Square and you
know go not on a fate you don't get a
mate and then everything is gonna hinge
on White's King does it have an Escape
Route where it can hide to a safe spot
or is it just going to be vulnerable to
the black queen chucking him forever and
ever yeah it's uh maybe the night goes
the other way but anyway a check would
always be met by a block and we do say a
knight is a king's best friend
let's see Ivanka mentioned no Checkmate
and unfortunately black has counter
threats against the white king
it's hard to see any progress here uh
what would what would you guys do in the
current position I think I would push
and then start to think yeah
um maybe the Knight can go this way as
well just maybe this is the safer one
it's a protected Square it'll go back
and then here I was thinking you know
I think uh White probably has to
establish a pawn chain first on the left
side
it's hard to achieve though oh yeah if
you push this Pawn forward and you want
to gobbled right you want to establish
this right so they all defend each other
so you can forget you kind of free up
your knight from the defense but
yeah unfortunately any pawn pushers will
always be met by a check
and the pawn would drop
yeah Anish
it's quite ugly what he's doing he's
just playing with his Queen Alone
um this does not I mean at least for me
as well it's not instinctive
um playing with the queen kind of
letting the black king and Knight defend
for themselves but he's just trying to
annoy David Anton essentially
frustrate him
interesting position kind of won't make
progress that's the question and David
Anton kind of needs to get his King into
the action yes yes so does he need a
niche to to check him with the queen so
we can move one square forwards yeah
yeah any black checks would actually
help the white king go where it wants to
go so ideally White's King wants to step
forward to the second rank maybe even
the third rank uh maybe even the fourth
rank
keep dancing forward because the king
would really get checkmated if you're
careful but at the moment it's just a
Target if it's abandoned by White Queen
and Knight
what do you think right now what will be
the result in this game I'm gonna say
it's gonna be a draw okay I think
black's Queen is it's
just too good I mean what Niche is doing
I think it's ugly but a satisfactory and
uh that is why David Anton has captured
the pawn wow wow instead of pushing it
Forward yeah that that wasn't even on my
radar because he's voluntarily taking a
wrecking ball to his pawns over there on
the right I mean look at them they're so
ugly they're all disconnected we don't
like that here in the studio do we we
like pretty porns but now I mean two
Harry's are better than one it has two H
pawns and that's a concrete idea right
Ivanka it does certainly does
so um now we were expecting the pawn to
push forward this is what we call a
sorry a harmonious Pawn chain at one
point Island to use Lawrence's
terminology but now this is not one pole
Island these don't defend each other but
the whole idea is that whites are
pulling up temporarily and if black goes
to recapture the pawn white can give a
check hitting the black king the king
has to move and now this Pawn is loose
so you couldn't actually give this check
while the Knight previously sat
defending the square but now it's
possible and you gobble up a pawn you
hit the Black Knight you hit the sky as
well you hit this pawn and it looks a
bit scary for black okay that look kind
of good yeah it looks good and you also
have to be careful of the white king the
white king is out in the open but I
think David Anton has spent his time he
spent two minutes on this move it was
calculating that White's King was safe
and this is why we say Knight is a
king's Best Friend the King is all alone
here it looks like it's about to get
checkmated if anything but the White
Knight can just sit back and block and
knights are actually so good at stopping
the black uh the opponent's Queen from
tracking the white king
just the perfect bodyguard this white
knight and white has won a pawn
so interesting for Anish Gary in the
current position he wants to win a pawn
back of course but can he do that right
now if the answer is no then actually
this Pawn is going to push forward and
it's going to be like a battering ram
just going to open up the black king
even further I think I think he has to
take that ball to be honest with you and
he has to gamble on perhaps the queen
and Knight coordinating together and
otherwise like David highlights that
pawn is going to step forward and it's
going to be a wrecking ball to Black's
position I'm going to say David Anton's
going to win this I think he's just
playing really well
um black should have still have enough
drawing chances or drawing resources but
Anish is the one under pressure and his
whole mentality the whole game has been
to try to draw and
we've seen that on the tors backfire so
many times on any player if they're just
playing with one result in mind playing
a bit negative absolutely so yeah a long
way to go but
heating up so Kai I have to ask you a
question what do you think of an issue
anisha's thinking pose
because this is such a common chess
players
pose you know we sit there with our head
and the heads do you think that makes us
look super smart super focused or does
it just look a bit strange
ha
I it looks sensible yeah that's
practical he's holding up the heaviest
part of his body yeah but I was just
wondering why did we do this
yeah I mean no when I do it it's either
because I'm trying to block out the
distraction just block out all the light
or the the audience or any anything or
it's because I've just I know my
position's bad and I'm trying to pretend
that nobody else can see nobody else can
look into my eyes
what's your thinking post then uh Lauren
well I tend not to think that's uh
that's a bad idea I think
oh that's one or oh I've seen you do
that so many times with that yeah I've
got the resting hand I've got that one
I'm not really an armed cross guy
occasionally
um
I've seen you do that though yeah yeah
you're right to do that if I'm acting
confident or if I'm genuinely confident
no that's definitely one of your poses
um
because it's instinctive right you don't
even yes you don't even think about it
Ivan Chuck who played didn't he he's got
a famous pose he Twirls his eyebrows
that's uh Magnus is often back in his
chair like
he's got his leg off yeah yeah yeah yeah
completely relaxed you know we're all
trembling
up no problem
yeah I love this move I mean just
returning to this game and you should
have spent four and a half minutes here
that is a long time and uh
fair play to David Anton for uh for
finding this move because G5 is the
automatic move and you're probably right
the night reroutes and it's not easy in
that now I need feeling a little bit of
the pressure actually he wouldn't have
expected this one either right thinking
for five minutes now Anish
I was going to say earlier Black's one
Saving Grace was his clock Advantage
Anish giri but now he's lower on time
he's the one defending remember black uh
he's long-term ecstatically he's worse
uh dynamically right now black has some
uh problems as well and
yeah I mean credit to David Anton this
last move I think that's the toughest
thing in chess is breaking down your own
kind of uh stereotypes your dogmatic
thinking um so we would think okay keep
the pawn structure and France forward
nice and intact control but he's just
saying no I'm willing to lose control
I'm willing to worsen my import
structure because it works in this one
specific moment and okay that's a check
also not working forward yeah and uh the
move the King has moved on to a row it
wants to be
it will do
just so that the queen was not able to
check the king along the G line and uh
is this nice
yeah this must be good news for David
Anton
I mean this is the
it would normally want to step forward
if we'd seen the pawn structure block up
earlier but it can't really step forward
now
um again there's a specific reason
um the white king it would love to kind
of step forward and maybe kind of head
into the black camp on a good day but
now if it steps forward the problem is
then I take the pawn with check so this
is the difference it comes with Tempo
white king now is too far out in the in
the open for example you don't want to
step forward anymore because the black
queen swoops behind and this would end
in Checkmate so we still have to be
careful despite the fact it's an endgame
with our King we can't allow this to
happen with Trek the problem is here
black wants to take this Pawn if we get
time now for white to come and check
then white would be doing well maybe
even winning but uh it comes with time
so David Anton in the current position
if you can't step forward what does he
do does he go back does he block with
the white knight if you block with the
white knight you lose this Pawn if you
block with the White Queen you lose this
Pawn so there's downsides to every move
right now but you can play for example
King F1 here David and if I keep
checking it now you check and now I can
try Queenie one I can try it
I'm blocking I guess the question is
what would happen for example in an end
game if the Queen's disappear and now
black can win his Pawn back yeah and
this is the end game you have it feels
like wait one second go on because uh we
were thinking about the king retreating
but we were not expecting the Knight to
take a step backwards he's just
abandoned his Queen side so David
downtown he's going all in yeah if this
was poker he's just pushed all his chips
to the center
um he's saying okay have all my pawns I
don't even care I'm gonna go for your
king and he's pushed this guy forward
he's trying to ask Anish direct
questions so this is where you mentioned
Kaya earlier damonaton is he gonna kind
of gamble at some point is he going to
take risks and this is the moment now
Anish has to decide what to do with his
King he willingly captures the pawn it
was too strong but now the black king is
a bit open I can even take this Pawn for
example
uh I guess anisha's idea if he takes the
spawn attacking the Knight is the black
queen can come back and defend uh this
would be a check and some nasty threats
if White's not careful here if white
blocks for example with the Knight you
always have to look out for tactics
White's Queen is undefended and a knight
check would hit the king hit the queen
and when the Knight disappears suddenly
we realized discovered attack and the
White Queen would drop and we might see
this variation on the board
won't fall into that tactic but uh maybe
we'll see Anish Gary bring his Queen
back heart to the defense this is
sharpening up really nicely you know
because Black's King could potentially
be under Fire within the next few moves
and there's still a lot of pitfalls to
navigate
wow you need to somehow teleport the
White Knight to F5 again the dream
square and then the blacking is doomed
yeah it takes a while yeah kind of like
the mission is get that Knight to the F5
Square without allowing black a
Perpetual check if you can do that
you're gonna win
yeah and four minutes against two
minutes Anish giri now it's harder to
defend an attack that's the that's the
cliche here's a big moment David yeah
he's got a movie gotta move the king
don't don't pick up the night you could
block with the White Queen that would be
an interesting question offering a queen
trade if the White Queen jumps back
but in a Muslim situation
I'm not sure you want to calculate a
night end game white pawns are all
shattered now they're it's white with
four isolated Pawns
so it's unclear if an end game would
suit white and we do have one big result
we needed to start it out today with 14
points one points less than David Anton
has just won his game against the detail
metal three points so that means Vita is
now on 17 points one point behind Anish
giri before this game
also going to be hoping that it that
David Anton can take some points off
gear yeah yeah
um yeah unfortunately for vidit he
actually lost in his game to Anish so
that in their head to head he has the
inferior tie break so he'll be hoping to
grab the points from Richard Rapport
yeah and we know what I say well those
two aren't safe anyway no definitely not
hey David Anton he does decide to bring
his Queen back I think this is a good
decision because Anish is the one who
has to calculate furiously whether this
end game is uh survivable yeah the thing
is if black takes the White Queen now
then white king will recapture and white
king is perfectly placed in the center
so it's a bit like earlier uh Lawrence
where that trade of Rooks it's like yes
you can exchange but on my terms
what do we think David Anton he can
avoid the queen trade again now the you
can block this tension between the
Queens with the White Knight
yeah he can do that he can
he can even
I've got a Str it's a bit strange the
move Queen D4 what if I centralize the
queen and the idea is that after Queen
64 I actually want to play the
completely counter-intuitive move C
takes D4
the idea being that if the night now
goes to B6 you now play Knight C3 uh and
A5 is a threat in some variations odds
and the Knight looks poor and the King
can come round via G3 F4 and the H Pawn
will happily distract the black king so
the black king can't get too centralized
and yeah and if you don't play Knight to
B6 I'm gonna go Knight to C3 anyway on
the next move and if you put the Knight
on F6 I have a similar plan of walking
in the King on the dark squares it's a
very unconventional idea but it makes
some sense it's uh it's probably not
good enough but
it's a sort of move
that can be annoying yeah what do you
think David I like that one too I mean
the first move that I'm attracted to
just because Black's King is very open
is to keeping the Queens on the board so
blocking the queen exchange White's
Knight is perfect in the center and
there are ideas now coming with a check
for example or coming to the board with
a check at least if I needed to win this
game I would probably try and do this
first but like you say Lawrence uh David
Anton we saw his aim chest stats earlier
very good in the end game he could maybe
say yes Queen trade but on my terms uh
very interesting move so okay he spent a
long time there and he does allow the
queen exchange he goes after this Pawn
instead
now the big question is uh maybe that
variation you showed if the Queens
disappear black can now go for this
white Pawn
hmm
and don't like this at all the Queens
have disappeared and nishi's gonna go
for this pawn and you can't keep it
alive if you step it forward then black
comes in with a check and the next move
picks up this Pawn
things are starting to disappear
surely this helps a niche it should do
but after King D4 Knight takes A4 Knight
takes 25 visits so easy to play for
black
um not easy but there's only three pawns
left but my king is very close to just
walking in and pac-maning yeah
yeah possibly
feels like there shouldn't be enough
left and we actually feels feels like
that yeah yeah we're heading in this
direction this is the current position
and uh
yeah it's again it's Rook spawns nice
and notoriously bad at stopping these uh
Corner pawns H pawns and a pawns because
they can only stop them from one side of
the board so Black's King is actually
going to go and deal with one and he's
anisha's gonna hope that his Knight can
deal with this white porn
it's a race who is going to be quicker
gobbling up pawns with their King
and okay down that one just happily
pushes forward
ah I just think he's coming and what do
you do against that
you're gonna have to put the Knight into
a defensive square if you want to guard
against the black king stop making
advancing yeah but then again you know
you're just going backwards you're not
coming forwards and I agree with you
put a knight on his Square not enough
pawns to cause any serious trouble to
Anish
yeah and he's doing a good job of
defending this one
it feels to me like David Anton could
have kept the Queens on maybe should
have kept the Queens on the board
earlier
so this is the current position
big threat initiary to come and win
White's isolated each point
all right the clock is ticking down did
you see that it's coming out to one
minute one minute left uh these are the
current standings a bunch of games have
finished Anish giri and Richard report
both are still on 18 points per V that
he is now on 17 after winning his game
David Anton on 15 if he wins this game
will be on 18 same as Anish and Richard
if it is a draw he will be on 16 points
Arjun eragisi is still playing his game
gukesh he has lost his game he is stuck
on 21 a win for Vincent kymer
breaking a terrible downtrend but he was
he lost five in a row incredible so it
was this is it was an important bounce
back game oh of course he's out of the
running but he's still for his
confidence he's not yet Lawrence oh
actually he might not get 0.3 chance
two more games 21 points could be enough
he needs all the results to go his work
and that's your eye breaks as well yeah
big ask yeah there was a tournament that
you and I commentated on you last year
Ivanka and the challenges tour where
before the final day I think it was good
cash yeah it was he had 0.3 chance of
winning the tournament but he wanted his
games
it's possible yeah
nothing uh yeah never say never in chess
yeah and for Vince and kymer then well
he will
hope for draws mostly and here we do
have a draw yeah it looks like David
Anton with that last move just offered a
draw simply running out of Pawns Black's
king would take a pawn by tonight would
take a pawn and everything would just
disappear